la invasión de ucrania está resultando
más difícil de lo que putin esperaba en
el séptimo día de guerra las fuerzas
armadas de moscú se encuentran con una
fuerte resistencia sobre el terreno
entre los militares rusos se han
producido más bajas de lo previsto y así
como problemas logísticos rusia enfrenta
dificultades para hacer llegar sus
suministros a todas sus tropas a lo
ancho del vasto territorio ucraniano en
un batallón ruso hay diez camiones eso
es todo eso proporciona autonomía
durante 48 horas después toda la unidad
tiene que detenerse hasta conseguir más
combustible y descansar la logística de
las fuerzas armadas rusas simplemente no
es suficiente para sostener operaciones
prolongadas en territorio hostil esta
podría ser la razón por la que el convoy
de 60 kilómetros de tanques rusos
todavía no ha entrado en kiev las
brigadas de blindados penetrando
lentamente en la capital eran un plan
vez después de que ucrania derribar a
los helicópteros rusos de combate que
tenían la misión de tomar por sorpresa a
la capital el día 1
la ofensiva rusa no avanza como estaba
previsto no se han alcanzado los
principales objetivos e incluso en la
doctrina rusa sabemos que si no se es
capaz de conseguir los objetivos clave
en las primeras horas añadir más tropas
invertir más días no va a hacer que la
operación sea un éxito when you make the
estos extras o operation en los últimos
días rusia ha aumentado sus ataques
aéreos contra grandes ciudades como
contra heart con fe en el este y odessa
mariupol y gerson en el sur lo que
podría significar un cambio de
estrategia en chechenia y siria moscú
usó artillería y bombardeos para reducir
el terreno a cenizas
de hecho podría ser una maniobra
deliberada y otras ciudades en ucrania
se están desgastando y la moral irá
bajando y en ese momento el convoy ruso
rodea que empieza el bombardeo de la
ciudad y luego el bombardeo con
artillería pesada no creo que tengamos
que asumir que rusia esté cerca de
retirarse de este conflicto
moscú renovó sus amenazas de escalada el
martes después de que putin ordenara
poner en alerta su arsenal nuclear
por otro lado el ministro de defensa de
ucrania dice tener pruebas de que el
ejército de belarús se prepara para
enviar tropas de apoyo a rusia una
información que el presidente alexander
lukashenko niega